today is in the end game for today i
prepared something very interesting and
games i
found when i was going over the games
from the
new inches classic that has been
finished like i think yesterday or two
days ago i was
entirely sure like within last few days
which magnus carson
won in the final against hikaru nakamura
so
yeah so i found very several interesting
end games
in this tournament and i wanted to share
with you
today um my discoveries
some of them are i think pretty
interesting
so i prefer in total four games
i am not entirely sure if we can cover
all of them today because it's
pretty quite extensive they were pretty
some of them were pretty expensive
but uh i hope that we can cover at least
three so this is what i would like to
aim at
all right so uh let's
let's get started so the first one
actually i
i found the the phone very interesting
is the game between
11 aaronian which is already here on the
board
against um
[Music]
in which
this position at some point arrives on
the board actually flip it from black's
perspective
of course black is completely winning
completely winning they're
like what three extra pounds right
and the position is wait let me double
check
if obvious shows well maybe i should
adjust maybe my leeches board here
yeah like this
yeah looks like this is better i think
maybe okay like this is i think
fine okay let's keep it like this uh
okay so this game
as i was saying black is completely
winning here there are three extra pawns
however i really really like the
technique that the shakhtar media
demonstrated
and won this game so
in this position uh
many moves with knight c free wins rook
f4 wins look at three wins there are
literally number of ways to win this
game here with pluck
but uh chakrier played very interesting
move rook to f1
ideal rogue f1 is of course to meet root
as one of the ng3 fork
and after kg2 knight xf1
king takes f1 and now we enter this
position so essentially
um shakarya momodarov gave away a piece
but it's important to note that he has
so many pawns right now and they
will be pushed very quickly forward
and that's what he does a3 so uh the
because because this a pawn is so
advanced knight from
g4 has to go back all the way to
c2 and then eventually maybe even a1 to
stop the spawn
and this now will be very passive then
uh
in this position your design will be so
passive black will be
able to sort of again pushing the g pawn
and basically win the end game win this
end game
on two weaknesses and
this is exactly what happened so let's
see
93 a2 knight c2 and now
king starts marching king g8 king h7 was
also possible the moment of uh chose
king g8
king e2 king f7 king d2 king f6
perhaps as i was saying earlier kingston
was slightly more accurate but
pretty much doesn't affect any anything
here any evaluation of the position
still black is completely winning king
c3
so uh of course it will be great for
white uh if
like this pawn could be captured
but the point is that uh right now black
is
sorry white is not in time to both
capture the point and then
head back the king side and this
position probably are many ways to win
this
but i really like again what the
shakhriar
played in this position so
black to play do you have any ideas
you've seen the game of course you know
the solution but uh
still maybe someone didn't see this game
so i would like to ask
what would you play right now here with
black
king g5 correct king g5 this is the
probably the best move uh kenji [ __ ]
a four yes
basically we need to activate the king
first before pushing the pawn
uh we should activate the king probably
also g5 g4 and then king g5 king of four
wins
but usually the good strategy is to play
at first king fighting king king f4 and
this is exactly what
uh shakurya played king g5
in b2 king f4 king takes a2 of course
has to be captured but this king right
now is very very far away from the king
side and now
g5 simply goes forward and the
white king is simply too far away and so
knight will not be able to stop
the g-pawn
effectively and successfully because in
best case the pawn the g2
the g pawn will be traded for night and
white will uh wha blah will have
winning pawn end game and this is
precisely what happened
king b3 trying to earth by the king g4
king c4 okay just g3
knight to e1 again king goes forward
king to e3
f1 is threatening king of two so knight
two is the only move
king f2 knight h4 and finally simply g2
into hg2 and this end game this point
game simply winning
if after king d5 of the king five of
course
it's very important actually that in
this initial end game that the
shakira went for this pawn was still on
a6
because right now this pawn pretty much
determines uh
that black is winning and decides the
game
simply a5 so um and after 26 a4
level orion resigned however uh
let's go back having seen this position
especially this one
right i would like to take a step back
and go to the initial position that i
that we started analyzing this one
right so if this pawn on a6 wasn't there
the entire line is not so clear
it's pretty much not clear if black can
win this maybe even white can win this
because knight captures the pawn
and as we have seen in this end game if
this
this position this pawn wasn't there
what what happens black
white is winning not black right so uh
you always just want one trying to say
that whenever you switch
uh kind of like you change the character
of the position and you go for you know
like rook f1 here and this is very
commental decision
you have to be really careful because uh
you need to really assess well you need
to be 100
sure that whatever you are going for
whatever calculated
is right because the margin of the error
is very very
small it's razor thin line so
uh that's why i believe that's why i
believe that this example is very
instructive
uh even though here you know black was
being pretty much everywhere
right sound in some positions things may
not be that simple
so that's why i wanted to show this
example
uh all right so let's go to the next
next game that i prepared
next game i prepared was i think from
the final game
uh between magnus and hikaru
mangos and hikaru and this was the queen
and game this
end game was also very interesting uh
let me
just f7 yes
so uh this is the position i want to
talk about right now we are interested
from wise perspective
so let's look at this position uh
seemingly
it's only extra pawn right it was one
extra pawn
this white king is very exposed as well
can run into
number of checks
and you know it's only one extra pawn
pawn before is under attack
potentially if before pawn is gone then
a4 pawn also will be gone
it seems like the game is pretty pretty
close
right however i think that what
the technique that magnus presented in
this game is very
[Music]
very very instructive as well and
there is also to learn from also having
in mind that
queen endings are particular
are in particularly difficult i would
say
why because it doesn't really matter uh
okay of course material matters who but
what matters most
is who has the postpone and
if how how is the king safety
so especially in this position white's
king seems to be totally exposed right
there is only one okay not only there's
no pawn on the free but still
it's pre-exposed can you run into a
number of checks
so what white should do to win this and
here
uh magnus demonstrated very nice uh
technique
of uh centralization
basically if you guys
pay attention to this game and how many
play he
always had his queen centralized and
active
then do the total maximum
so that's what i wanted to show in this
game so
uh yes mj yes
magnus played queen eight correct
however uh let's understand
uh what's the general strategy before we
even start moving the
scene news in the game i would like to
explain the
what is the general strategy as i was
already saying
white king needs to be centralized but
it must be done in very specific way
the queen should be basically holding
this pawn before and pawn on f3 somehow
and with the queen centralized in the
middle of the board
it would be difficult for black to avoid
same time
you know trading of queens because
pretty much nearly all poland games will
be winning for white
because uh you know will be why we have
why has extra point upon game and
potentially will be easier to create a
past pawn
so because of that it will be very
difficult for black to you know
uh keep the queen active
and avoid the same time
you know queen trade and if this black
screen is not attractive
then white's king will have and and
what's black skin is
black's queen is not that active and
white white's queen defends all the
pawns
then white king can simply go
forward and hide
be in front of the pawn sometimes
someone's behind the pawns we always
have support will always have support
from the queen
and potentially even maybe can win uh
you know
black pawns so let's this is the general
strategy but first thing we need to
centralize the queen so mouse playing
with queen e8
king c7 and now simply queen to e4 no
reason to give ren in random checks
uh like queen seven i mean queen eight
head idea had a very clear idea of
bringing the queen to e4
so this makes this check make sense but
after g7 there is no reason to start you
know throwing queen c7 you know maybe
some new queens f7 back no queen e4
for now queen e4 there is no any checks
for two black white's king
queen gets centralized opponents are
defended
and this is this and right now black is
this black stern
and black always has to watch out for
all the possible queen traits for
example already queen c1 will run into
queen f4
for example queen c1 queen f4 already
trades queens and white has winning pawn
end game
therefore makikar plays with king d6
and now we begin activating king king to
g4
trying to play f4 and uh
you know making made skin pretty much
safe of course
in such end games is it possible to
calculate you know everything what you
have to do
and first is just to focus on basically
achieving accomplishing one thing at a
time so
uh right now first i will activate the
queen and centralize the queen on e4
and then slowly push the king forward
then make sure all pawns are protected
and slowly and slowly gradually improve
your position
so right now queen d3 has been played
king d7
queen e3 few checks and now
queen gets to c5 taking attacking into
our
account that right now the queen on a1
has no checks neither from d4 or g1
squares because
queen covers both and covers everything
on this diagonal
right so queen gets a little bit more
activated
so this makes sense king g8 king f4
still okay there is one check on f6 but
very you know still still king will go
to the center
21 and now king goes to e5 finally
the king gets activated and
the point is that queen f3 doesn't
really work because
white can play against queen to d5 and
the gameplay pawn ending is winning
because white after queen d5 queen takes
d5
is first to create a past pawn here on
the queen side and win the game
black black king is too far away from
the king size from the queen side
to stop those pawns so queen takes the 3
wasn't possible
and white activates the king and this is
generally you know a good strategy
ideally the king may be in
some at some point the future will go
towards a sixth pawn and simply capture
this pawn
and to be honest this is what happened
again so king h7
uh queen d5 keeping everything defended
again there are not many good squares to
give child let's say queen two some
possible call of queen e4 again
so uh queen a4 has been played queenie
for back
king h8 and now king d6 perfect strategy
so queen was maneuvering around and with
proper checks
and uh shielding from black's queen
king was able to get from g3
all the way to d6 already and what luck
didn't do
why did they do anything special apart
from that
but this is the best way to play and
[Music]
for black it's impossible to defend this
end game pretty much because of this
strategy that y employs with the
centralization of the queen
and always controlling for your
opponent's counter play
once this is accomplished there is
pretty much no hope here for
for black so queen b5 followed again
king c7 king goes towards the queen side
and ideally towards this
a6 pawn and trying to win it
uh king g8 queen e6 check again few
checks
uh one this time queen d6 activate the
king
the queen a little bit queen e2 and
finally f4 you can see
um die contour in this game i
think i i'm not and
i think it was rapid i think it was
rapid still
like 15 plus 10 15 50 minutes plus 10
seconds
if i'm not mistaken so uh but i could be
wrong i could be wrong
anyway so here f4 right
after f4 queen on d6 covers both pawns
king is already not on g3 but already on
c7
and wants to get to a7 at some point and
try to resume simply day6
and that's the entire you know strategy
so uh once again
white needs to simply control whatever
black is doing make sure all pawns are
protected
and ideally win the a6 points some point
back after activating the king
that's that's pretty much about it and
after queen b5 okay queen c5
queen h5 throwing some checks
throwing some checks again very nice way
to put the queen on e4
with 10 p and right now
queen is defining both pawns again from
the central square
defends both pawns right and now
uh the king finally has a possibility to
move to b6
and after queen b5 king goes to a7
king certainly savior on a7 and pawn a6
evidently becomes a target that white
will
try to capture within next couple of
moves
still hikaru was fighting with queen f1
queen queen e8 again few checks
to you know activate the queen a little
bit and finally move
f5 so what is the idea of f5 potentially
at some point in the future maybe
[Music]
magnus wants to put the queen on g6 and
then capture on
uh the pawn e6 with with some checks or
something
potentially but most importantly it's
very difficult to defend uh you know
keep defending this pawn on a6
because for example you know queen has
limited number of moves
four squares are not available because
with the screen here on d5 and if queen
e2
this didn't happen the game magnus can
play for instance queen e6
this is also uh important because right
now
after f5 the queen supported here and
attacks this pawn and also presents
queen g6 maybe and sometimes
so the game is just pretty much decided
so
um hikaru tried queen b1 after which
[Music]
magnus decided to defend
this pawn rather than the opponent 5 and
he played with queen d6
but he makes sure that he captures pawn
a6 and he will have two double pawns
to connect the pawns on the queen side
which will promote the queen
and the rest of the game is pretty much
self-explanatory
but the idea of bringing the king from
g3 all the way you know like gf4 e5 d67
finally b6
b6 and a7 finally to get to the
surrounding spawn a6 let me just maybe
move it back here
to this position
so the king sorry king moved like this
right just to get to a7 to surround pawn
on
a6 is a very very instructive idea in my
opinion
and all this was possible because of the
centralized white queen which was always
uh defending both pawns up to this
moment when
you know basically there was a trade for
f pawn for the a6 pawn
okay so king takes a6
uh g5 and uh yeah basically
white pawns are simply much faster and
the game is just over so let's just see
until the end queen f1 king b6 king f2
the queen of firemen queen c5
queen b6 king a7 future is still
accuracy needed
but in general uh bones go
forward g3 b7 uh queen f1 king a7
queen f2 of course we shouldn't try it
on f2 so that's why
uh play uh once play queen b6
and b8 queen is a threat uh after queen
f7
uh queen b1 king h6 of course is already
winning
and after queen g7 i don't know if like
lost some time or something but anyway
position was lost because
or maybe he just resigned because magnus
can play for instance right now queen h4
uh king g6 queen g3 and winning the g
free pawn and the game is just over
so uh this was a very interesting i
believe
even though it was pretty
straightforward
uh uh so you know like already here with
those two pawns but the idea of bringing
the king
to a7 and all the way from g3 and
keeping the center of the
queen uh centralized is
i think very very uh important uh
okay some questions the child why uh
queen
g7 uh well i don't know but anyway
position is already lost
position is already already lost there
is no way to
save this so i don't know why queen g7
but
anyway nothing else worked anyway so he
was winning already for white
and one quintex b6 then g2 g1
you mean this
yes i will take
no queen f7 uh what do you mean i'm
confused
you mean this queen b6 right
yeah i guess i'll take take uh b8 queen
uh juban queen yes this was better
defense this was uh
presumably better defense but uh
still i believe that should be winning
i believe that still this should be
winning
uh i kind of didn't analyze this much
already like i just thought this was
winning i kind of like skimmed through
it
but i i agree this was better defense
still it should be
uh winning in number a number of ways
one of the important one the
possibilities is for instance play move
queen e5 again
uh you know another unknown the only way
but one of the possible ways
to first of all centralize the queen and
with b pawn i believe this should be
winning
i can double check quickly but uh
yes this is design game is winning i
quickly double checked
and this game is winning uh you know at
some point this pawn will promote
the uh to the queen uh usually
the best defense with this with this
king is to be let's say i think in this
corner
like around those squares because here
if his king is here
there are always possibilities to kind
of cover from checks with
check to black's king and try to trade
queens obviously
so i think queen d6 or something like
that uh
played at some point you know get to
play king eight or
b7 and queen b8 maybe at some point and
somehow black white will have one over
here but i agree this was still the best
defense
okay uh anyway it was very nice
technique here by
uh magnus and
the idea of king going marking marching
through
from g3 to a7 is very very instructive
all right so next game i wanted to show
uh
a game of hikaru this time versus uh
liam the lakwang
and this was also an interesting end
game this time hikaru won
and the end game i was i was curious to
talk about
is the following end game actually this
this end game
so the last movie rook takes a four uh
white uh
big i mean hicaro with white pieces
captured upon and still has extra pawn
but the end game is pretty
pretty close i would say because
in this position there are only problems
on the one side of the board
and of course white has huge huge
chances to win
there are still posts there are still
certain defensive resources especially
with
uh if black manages to activate his rook
and if you know it's not so easy to push
those pawns
white pawns forward so after bishop b6
this is what uh liam played
f4 how happened by caro
and right now it was a very important
moment in this game
so i would like to ask you what what do
you think should
black play in this position
g6h5 imani says also g6
okay
i agree this seems like an optimal setup
correct
any other ideas
because far we have only one idea
usually it's good to have some candid
moves here so apart from g6
activate uh the rook first uh
of seven points week well i don't know
if some point is weak like it's well
defined by the bishop right
and the king
mostly by the bishop because you
activate the rook or something then
uh you know the background would be an
issue and uh
if f5 then you know or sorry rook a8
let's say black rules go somewhere up
the up the board let's say you know to
be free b2 or b1 and at some point we'll
play rook a8
the king will have to go from the h
frank from the from eighth franc
and uh only bishop will be supporting f7
right
money i disagree with you because
oh sorry not money a chess king if g6 g6
and if g4 h5 black seems okay
i disagree with you because
i can play for instance move f5
rook b2 you looked at for example but i
don't
get anything from that okay
so in general there are three ideas
right
or two ideas
yeah so um okay let me start with g6
g6 i think is not that great because of
g4 and then
uh if h5 will play simply f5
and you know you're not going to break
my pawn structure actually i'm kicking a
bishop out of e6
and i have y has very very good winning
chances
so this is not so not so great
um king of eight your kind of move
well king of 8 seems kind of passive
like i'll just play g4 either way
and you know just push my phones forward
all right so here is the thing one of
you said actually the right
idea here
one of you said the right idea so let me
so let me uh let me say something so
in general this type of this type of end
game you need to look for counter play
like uh if you just defend passively the
white pawns will just
you know march for sorry ma will they
they will march forward
the king will come to support them you
know like uh
and you know this will be pretty much
over
very very quickly wise plan is super
simple
so the only way to uh sort of do
something here with
and you know with black and the idea
that of g6 or h5
still not sufficient because i can still
play g4 h5 and then bring my king
forward and so on
so this is not this is not the way to go
here with black what black has to do
here
is to look for counter play and the
counter play can be achieved by
activating the rook
and exactly
mj uh rook b1 king h2
and rook b2 is the way to go first of
all black
stops idea of g4 this is the first and
foremost
idea of g4 and uh once this idea is
stopped
oh there's also a idea from black side
to play move bishop d5
and capture simply pawn on g2 because of
the pin
and this is the best by far the best
defense pretty much is the only
hope here that black can uh hope black
can try to save this game
so you know activity activity of pieces
uh
rook b1 the king f2 leads to a similar
thing uh probably i mean this
uh you know rook b2 now here just play
for instance
rook d4 and again uh right now
we need to somehow activate our pieces
because still if
white manages to easily activate you
know kind of get out of this let's say
pin with the king a girl of the spin
with the king and
uh forward white will win so again we
should
try to activate the bishop again this
time for d7 and
again they then get to c6 to put
pressure on g2
and suddenly it's not entirely trivial
to win this
black has i think sufficient counter
chances out of nowhere
even though it seems like white should
be somewhat winning it's sim
it appears to be not so easy and uh
of course if white plays knight e4 or
something like bishop c6
the after tray sorry after trade of the
you know minor pieces the game should be
just drawn
because four versus three should be
definitely
drawn so um
i actually had a video about four versus
free uh
for instance from like i think last year
so uh
you can watch it again uh if you didn't
watch it
or like if you watched some time ago and
you don't remember
or if you didn't watch it also you know
there is some stuff about four versus
three rook and games
anyway so here
i think the black head with this rook b1
rugby two idea
uh very good chances to save the game
there was also an idea for white play
king f2 and basically
ignore all of this and just play key
free for the activity
but if while goodbye goes for the
activity all right so now we can capture
the pawn already right it's not directly
more extra pawn
and position becomes very very tactical
and of course the f5 is to be checked
but again we should be free okay
king h7 and to be honest i don't see
a clear path for white to how to make
progress
pawn on f7 is defended by a freight but
still is the final the
vehicle is built upon b3 if the bishop
is attacked always can go to a2
um worst case scenario
and you know will be well defended at
least and
this bishop holds everything on this
diagonal
holds holds everything so uh
it's not easy to make progress here with
white analyze a little bit further let's
say king d4 does rub h2
going after the h3 pawn rook f8 and
just uh rook f2 this time basically for
meeting knight f7 with uh rook f5
and if h4 we can just find a check uh
stay back ideas also the often play rook
e3 attack this pawn
in general black has
should have sufficient compensation here
after h5 for instance
simply go after the throw in one check
and go after the
you know uh e5 point if king d4
potentially even rook c7 is fine
uh yeah i think dirksen is the easiest
actually just defend the pawn and
pretty much that's it before rookie
three rg8 simply we should d5 just stay
in place and
king's 5 should be too difficult it's
definitely very difficult to make
progress here we'll fight
proper then probably the game is just
wrong so this was the best
the best defense coming back again rook
to b1 was the best defense but
in the game fold rook 2 b2
wasn't ruger 397 possible due to rook
f59g5
let me see
you mean here i'll take a knife g5 kng6
but yeah good detail uh good detail i
will have kg6 here
if h5 i can i can take the knight so it
doesn't work
so yeah black black is fine here
but probably if i think about after king
g6 it is even wider
there's only one it takes the risk here
like uh i think black would just wins a
pawn out of nowhere
because uh you know ruger five can get
five
and if iphone is just gone
okay there is still knight f3 but i can
play bishop d1
probably white can make a draw somehow
but it's becoming
not not easy only black can win that
win this okay so um
coming back to the what happened in the
game the game for he rooked b2
instead so this gave immediately a
chance for hikaru to play with g4
but of course because it was a rapid
game right it was 15 plus 10.
uh hikaru decided to play a different
idea he played instead of rook
to d4 and g4 was better uh
g4 was better because attribution d5
simply rook d4
bishop g2 and rook d3 just covers
everything it was important to push this
pawn forward to make it
to advance with it and right now if
possible of course
uh why i would like to get the king to
g3 at some point not possible yet
because of course there's
bishop e4 let's say why is that a two is
wise idea is to play rook
c3 and then i really bring the king
forward
of course uh you know like sometimes can
happen white
as long as this king is not easily
getting to g3
white still has some hopes here to to
survive but in general
uh slowly but surely white should
eventually
make progress especially as bishop on d5
is very unstable
if bishop goes here we can even capture
respawn f7 suddenly
so this position is still very difficult
after rook d2
we can play f5 at some point we're gonna
play
uh k1 king f1 k1
to serve this mantle this setup of the
rook and the bishop
on d and d 25 squares
and you know slowly but surely white
will make progress here and
uh potentially and probably is just
winning for white
so this was possible already here didn't
do it
rook d4 was played and again
and again the same idea even though it
wasn't that great already
it still had to be played rugby one king
h2 and rook b2
again because this is the only way to
stop primo g4
only effective way to stop g4 and after
even after five just okay bishop a2
bishop as long as there's squares in
this diagonal
it is bishop is fine and again i
analyze it further but i couldn't find a
kind of like a clear path here for white
to win
always white is much better of course
there are lots of lots of chances
and it's already much trickier than you
know earlier but i would i
uh will be analyzed but still
pretty pretty close to a draw so
this was still the best defense but liam
played
move f5 so this was a very
very bad move but let's
see
let's see now what would you play with
white in this position
why to play what would you do
you
okay various ideas i can see
okay the password should be winning
not 100 sure
depending on the reactivity you don't
know i'm personally sure if it's winning
pretty close to a draw actually
uh the knight c4 bishop takes c4 i think
it should be with correct defense and
draw
but i'm saying very carefully uh
i do not i'm not 100 sure but i would
assume there's a way better defense than
with knights and bishops on the board
um
there's the okay there's the idea of to
play king h2
uh i think engage two is a little bit
i don't know like slow like uh
that doesn't take into consideration
what black wants to do
so uh king h2 i think is
a little bit careless i would say even
in such position
uh you have to be accurate there was
someone said here
earlier i can see that rook a4 is the
first
instinct or something um
right the first thing is to go rogue a4
here okay 4 is definitely
you know one of the possibilities
yeah okay for uh whether we had maybe
rookie 8 and then push the e pawn
one of the possibilities or the idea to
play luke a4 with a rook a7 knight e8
also possible so uh
so rook a4 is definitely a move uh you
know
but also you are suggesting move g4
right
in this position
for white
g4 is also interesting
this is definitely interesting but
i'm not entirely convinced by this idea
i see a logic of it but i do not
think is that great let's say if i play
i know even if g then f5 of course
yes but let's say after you know
g4 i'll play move like g6 or something
like i will keep it together i'll hold
it together
still your king is cut off on the back
rank
right now already fred will take on g4
so i guess you have to take blackboard
has to take
i take back
actually i don't take back the pawn my
bad
i will take here with the bishop to keep
it activate to kick it
activate it if knight exit 5 the ball is
a 5. and as i was saying
like rook take rook and game like this
is not necessarily
easy uh to to win if you play rook d6
i'll go to b4 for instance
you'll be much let's say better for what
this king was let's say already on g3
but it's cut on the second rank it's not
entirely trivial to
make progress here with white
knight c493 well again uh if you play
knight c4 i'm gonna play probably just
knight bishop takes c4
uh but also also wait i can play rook b4
if i finger before is the cleanest you
have to play with d8 otherwise you are
just losing a piece right
roughly let's say i go k7 and you think
you're gonna lose the four pawn
right now
so this is uh not great for for
it
[Music]
okay let me show you what hikaru played
he carol played
what someone suggested rook a4
and this is as you can see on the
picture on the diagram
it is a mistake
it is a mistake so why is that why is
the mistake
okay you've come up with this refutation
of this idea
because rook a4 is very natural
obviously try to activate the rook try
to get the knight
to eight attack point g7 or maybe go to
gate rook e8
all those ideas are i agree with them
like they are pretty good ideas
but what can black do right now what is
the
resource that black has in this position
that pretty much saves the
game for for black
bishop d5 is possible but i will play
simply g3 afterwards
bishop d5 is simply g3 and
you cannot uh i mean you can take your
play rule g3 rujitu and rook g3 but i
will
uh i think there is a problem with it
uh i will play then
simply net x5 right and uh there is a
problem the
time rook being attacked and also fork
with knight e7
right
like do you see what i'm trying to say
like if you play bishop d5
i'm going to play knight xf5 hg2 king f1
and uh right now
sorry my bad my bad what i'm talking
about g3 g3 of course
my bad uh g2 king f1 nairo g3 knight f5
and rook is under attack
and so is 97 with the fork so
uh
and someone said here g5 yes
g5 is the best move g5 is the best move
and suddenly things are getting
uh not so clear and you say
that the g5 fg
g i guess an idea isn't clear to you
well is that clear to me as well but i
guess there's a good thing
right that's unclear because here we can
you know
here it's clear white is you know
much much better and certainly position
becomes unclear
well that's like as a good sign for
black right
so uh after rouge a4 uh
this is what uh liam played k7 and this
was lost
so uh g5 is a very good move after
you know text takes 98 let me just put
slowly it takes
takes 98
you know things are already you know not
so
not so obvious
like for example i can play after 98 you
know like i don't know king of seven
i don't see any problems here like okay
like without f6 and so on like
there's not even one check with this i
have 6 i don't know i can play almost
anything here like i can play f4 for
viking g6 like why would that block be
any worse here
yes basically g4 the sixth counter play
here for black
again similarly as as like earlier ruby
two
uh sorry rook b1 and rook b2 was looking
for contemporary connected with upon g2
right now black truly tries to find
counter play regarding challenging spawn
structure is pawn chain
and try to attack it weaken it and then
find counter play like that so
active counter play again so you say
the 80
the soul h4 instead of rouge a4 but it
doesn't unlock the structure
yes h4 is the best move h4 is the best
move and this move
pretty much wins this leads to a winning
position for white
uh g5 the only counterplay connector
that was here was with g5 and now it's
blocked
it's totally stopped and right now while
be able to slowly you know
first of all play at some point g3 will
secure everything bring the key into
queensland slowly advance everything
and the black has pretty much no defense
at some point the black's
defense is going to collapse because
there is no activity
available there's pretty much no
activity available after h4
uh black is just stuck and the fact that
the pawn structure is blown on the king
side is good for white
because it can black cannot destroy it
that kind of challenges move like g5 and
so on
and uh that's what white actually
actually wants because why the next
extra pawn
we don't need to look for pawn breaks
what we have to do
is you know improve our pieces and uh
you know there are if we activate our
pieces to correct squares some ideas
will eventually show up by
simply playing like rook a4 okay 798 for
instance we don't need to
win with pawns between our pieces here
so it is not probably
pawn structure is getting locked on the
king side
um okay so h4 it was uh
when you lead to a winning position does
make sense in general
all right i assume it does make sense
so uh i would like to i just want to
thank you for giving me
you're welcome god i can help glad i can
help
okay h4 all right so let's um
let's see what happened in the game rook
a4
and uh let him play king h7 of course it
was rapid game if this was
was not rapid game let's say or hit more
time probably he'll have played g5
because g5 seems pretty natural and
we'll change the spawn structure also
idea is
like if this there could be idea
pleasingly ruby free and
giving attacking point g3 and
throwing a bunch of checks here and
there and
this is you know not so easy to win also
so
uh but but king h7 is what he played and
right now uh hikaru
played a very strong rook a7 and the
game is pretty much already over
because the threat of rookie 7 and 98
frets of rookie 798 are irresistible
pretty much and again the rest of the
game is just
a nice technique here by hikaru and he
managed to win it
convincingly king g6 h4
group b4 which rookie seven
bishop out uh h5
uh winning the pawn g7 pawn f4
is lost true but right now of course it
doesn't really matter much because of
knight e8 the idea that was always there
but now it works perfectly because this
king is just so bad here on h5 that
unlike
also comes the fork and potentially also
later defrays the idea
so uh liam had to give the
bishop but of course with down being
down a piece in such position is
is just bad and after a few moves a few
few checks came to six
and here he car one because
there is nothing else to do here with
black
and here this is how the game ended so
anyway it was very interesting end game
very interesting end game especially the
defensive resources that black sheep
black had in this game
i think it's kind of unique because very
often such positions
it seems like okay it's like on playing
for two results either white wins or or
a draw and
generally this is this is true but still
black can put a little bit quite very
very big resistance
even in such end games
and yeah so i think it was very
interesting
all right so i prepared one more game
and i'm pretty sure
we know i'm not gonna cover and this
game in the instance
in its entirety because uh you know
the first three games took quite a lot
but
uh still i think uh i would like to
spend a few minutes on this on this game
as well so
uh
i mean higher miners are both great i'm
not saying that he carries any
like you know i'm not saying anything
bad about hikaru it's they're both great
players obviously
[Music]
so uh yeah i want to show one more game
here against uh between mathema rajabov
and uh
magnus so uh let me actually start from
the beginning i'm not gonna i'm gonna
pretty much skim through the game
uh because it's not that interesting uh
let's say here but here the end game
started pretty much
so after knight x e4 uh f5
this was i think novelty or one of the
rare moves
because there was a game bishop g7
and knight g3 f5 between tamo rojo
himself and wesley saw
in 2020 and in the game and withdraw
however i think after bishop d3 rookie
one knight f5 f4
tamer has some pressure but in the game
in the end the game
and ended up being a draw still probably
he found some improvements on the way
but magnus played here not bishop g7 but
f5 right away which is
pretty interesting so knight c5 uh king
f6
uh rook d8 this was i think i guess it
was preparation by magnus
uh king g7 represented bishop takes ajad
so what's the idea behind magnus
play here so in my opinion he
ignores the fact that you know his pawn
on b7 is hanging
in order to quickly develop his pieces
and look for active counter play
and that will holds the balance for
instance knight b7 knight c6
uh you know of course is a extra pawn
for white but black
should have sufficient compensation uh
because of this
dark dark square bishop on aj being
active
of course after play playing let's say
kingston or something uh
should be very active i have rook b8 and
so on
black should have enough compensation
here so uh
rotamer play bishop c4 which is a very
very good move
96 anyway
yeah the knights are traded of course
should be a draw comfortably
but we will see actually what happened
in the game
so i see six knight takes e6 and right
now i think magnus
mixed up something because he played 95
which i think is a little bit inaccurate
i think rook ca was very
strong and after king b1 only 95.
maybe he makes a move or something
because according to my analysis this
was linked to
total equal position uh however
and i mean however here minus p95 after
bishop d5 the difference is that
right now uh after rook c8 i don't have
to look in b1 but i can go king d1
or even king d2 but uh but king d1
according to balance is a little bit
more accurate
and after king d1 93 king d2 for
instance
tactically white has some chances here
of course black should probably equalize
the correct play but still is not so
easy according to my analysis
i want to go into detail this is not
that relevant this is what i want to
show for this game
but just to arrive at the position that
i want to talk about i had to start from
this
position so modern display 93 which is
already a big mistake because after
right now in king d2 um
cannot take on f2 i mean probably you
have to anyway but this is not uh
something you want to do because after
rook uh here
and knight e4 you should be [ __ ] e6
bishop f5 you're simply pawn down
and if knight g4 i assume that h3 and
g4 is simply winning upon as well
so uh white retains extra pawn
and very very good winning chances
that's why here
minus decide to play knight b4 looking
for counter play in this way
but uh this already allows among the
tambour to capture it upon b7
after b8 knight c5 rook d8
uh you know he has two extra pawns king
c3 knight a2 is of course
very shaky because knight may not simply
sk from a2
and after a5 a3 you know white
essentially has two extra phones
but manus managed to save this
he was pretty lucky though but still
managed to save this and i would like to
show
a very nice uh idea that how
by the way tamer played great so far
uh and this game and he put lots of
pressure on magnus king b3 knight d3
here in this position according to one
uh to engine king c2 was the most
accurate way to play
and by some you know weird
moves weird variations a com a computer
simply you know wins or something but
king c4 is a very human approach and i
really like
uh what uh taymor did here because after
ud7
c6 rook c7 king b5 bishop b2 he gave
one pawn away but he kept his king and
bishop active
and after a4 he there is only one extra
pawn but
with such active bishop and statue
active king and quickly activating the
rook to the game
the game is should be pretty much
winning and
he his technique was flawless up to a
point
rook c8 rook d1 bringing the pieces now
very important move f4 basically the
idea of f4 is to fix this pawn f5 as a
weakness
and further try to attack move like d5
bishop d7
and uh make sure that this rook will be
very passive on
f8 or somewhere on the f file uh
defending passively the pawn on f5
and this this is winning for white this
was perfect technique so far
r8 has been played king c4 bishop b4 of
course
rook comes to d5 as i said bishop d7 is
the idea
so um rook f8 bishop d7
h5 and g3 makes sense to make this pawn
chain
and some very very solid pawn chain
bishop p1 uh rook d6 throwing
some checks uh attack and win a tempo
so uh now king d4 very good move
and bishop e1 so here is the position i
want to actually talk about
and so far taymor you know as i was
saying
presents a great technique however right
now he started drifting maybe because of
the time pressure
most likely as we know rapid game
and he managed to spoil this
and unfortunately for him he didn't win
the game
so i wanted to show one very simple but
very neat idea how to win this the best
way to win this play moves
king to e3 and first of all make sure
there is no counter play on the queen
side
because the king will come to f3 and
support all the pawns on the king
side this is the first step basically
black hand cannot activate the rook
because this book is stuck to the pawn
f5 right
so if this is the case i can bring my
king to f3
and then i can look for ideas so this is
the first step so
let's say he plays h4 right trying to
activate this
of course even if h4 doesn't happen
there is no difference
h3 takes takes rook f6 so what is the
next step
next step is to simply bring this bishop
back to
d3 to create this spin on this king and
then play g4
and the game is just over so that's why
bishop b5
uh you know like bishop b4 for example
bishop d3
and the g4 follows even uh rook takes f5
should win and then g4 but
there is not even no reason to enter his
end game because g4 right away simply
wins
and if while and if black plays move
like
bishop rook b6 then bishop d3 as well
rook f6
at some he has to pretty much go back uh
rogue b3
uh seems to be king sorry g4
my bad g4 simply wins as well
so there is pretty much no no hope here
for black
just no hope and once the bishop comes
to
b5 and to d3 pretty much what easily is
limits the only thing that
millennium had to do is to bring this
king to f3 and
make sure there is no counter play
instead what he did
he played rudy says which was a little
bit inaccurate
and probably again he just had to go
kinky free
right now king e3 and try to bring this
king here and bring back rook to d5 and
revert to the same uh idea
uh still winning but he played rookie 6
was already you know
inaccurate again bishop b4 and finally
final mistake bishop v8 and after h4
uh magnus managed to bail out with a
draw
and this the game uh you know ended with
a draw
still after being said we should be
eight still there were assumptions of
king e5 and so on but it's already
way more complicated than it was because
the rook is not on d5 but on e6
and this gives black some better chances
to save the game
because pawn five is not that attacked
as it was
and the gifts pose it gives possibility
for the black group to get activated
for example we should see freaking d5
rook d8
uh king d6 we should be forking c7
and simply rook f5 maybe right now we'll
come from this side
and uh you know here with d5
fighting king g6 you know suddenly
somehow black
holds is not that obvious normally this
king should be there
you know like should be
common should be on f3 supporting both
spawns and bishop on d3
right but right now those pieces are
totally misplaced
right and so this is not entirely
trivial anymore
still wise some chances but black has
some chance to defend as well
but bishop b8 of course uh allowed h4
and after
pawn takes rook f6 suddenly uh
you know white pawn chain is totally
destroyed pawn f4 is potentially a
weakness
is a weakness and is impossible actually
to win anymore
the game ended uh very quickly
because uh yeah with next with next few
moves
uh yeah they just repeated probably uh
tamer panicked or made some mistake in
time trouble or something
but up to a point up to this point where
he
you know this moment he played flawless
if he gameplay this idea of king of
freedom bishop d3 uh bishop of fiber
d3 i believe he will have one
okay anyway
thank you uh very much for today a
little bit for me
from me for now uh i
will i hope i hope you guys uh found it
interesting
games and i will
see you tomorrow on twitch whenever i'll
be doing the
simul so uh thank you for today i will
see you
tomorrow
thanks take care bye